في الاستوديو معنا العميد الياس حناء
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي لا تتوقف
المعارك بشان ضخمه ولا يتوقف الحديث هناك
اختلاف في داخل كل بلد سواء في اوكرانيا
او في روسيا بين الطرف مثلا في اوكرانيا
يريد ان ينسحب طرب يريد ان يبقى والغلبه
يبدو للطلب الذي يريد ان يبقى ويدافع بشكل
مستميت عن المدينه وفي الجانب الروسي طبعا
التضارب المعروف بين فاجنر ووزاره الدفاع
الروسيه كيف ترى اصطفاف القوى بين
الجانبين بشان هذه المدينه تحديدا وحظوظ
الطرفين في الاستيلاء عليها
بالنسبه للشق الاوكراني
الفريقان يقولان انه الكلفه اصبحت كبيره
كبيره لهدف ليس مهم بالمعنى الاستراتيجي
الكبير ويجب الانسحاب كي لا نخسر النخب
الاساسيه
شق اخر يقول ان المعركه انتقلت من العسكر
الى السياسه ولا نريد ان نعطي الرئيس
بوتين نصرا بمكان ما اليوم الشق الاخر لدى
الروس روسيه او الجيش الروسي هناك خلاف
يعني هناك الجيش الرسمي البحريه المارينز
الروس الذين يقاتلون ولكن العبء الاكبر هو
على الذي يريد ان يحقق هدفا معين ليقول
لرئيس بوتين انا موجود ولكن هناك من يحاول
افشاله في هذه المرحله او استنزافه
للمرحله القادمه يعني تؤكل فاجنر في مخبوط
كي لا تستمر بعدها لان لدى
طموحات سياسيه وهذا ما حذره منه بطريقه
غير مباشره الرئيس بوتين
بصراحه لافت ان هذه المدينه بخمت اللي في
البدايه لم نكن نسمعها ابدا كنا نتحدث عن
ماريوكل وطبعا حديث كبير
الان باخ موت هي في الصداره الكل يتحدث عن
باخوت وزير الدفاع الامريكي رئيس الامريكي
طبعا ناهيك عن الطرفين المعنيين اساسا هل
فعلا يمكن القول بطريقه ما انا هذه قد
تكون
الجديده ام هذه مبالغه وكيف تختلف عن
مريوط
ماريوب المختلفه تماما ماريوبول مدينه
كبيره والمعركه الكبرى حصلت في معمل ازوف
ستال هذا في تلك المنطقه كانت قوات ازوف
التي اتهمها الرئيس بوتين بانها نازيه او
متشدده او مشابه ماريوبول تعطي نظره على
بحر ازوف يعني
استراتيجيه مهمه وهي من ضمن الجسر البري
الذي يربط
شبه جديد القرن اما محمود فهي من ضمن خط
يبدا منوف
الى مخموت وبالتالي الى اوغلي دار هذه
المنظار العام ولكن هي بحد ذاتها ليست هذه
الهدف الاستراتيجي المهم وهي مختلفه عن
مدينه كبيره
والجيش كانت نقطه التحول في خساره جيش
المانيا ايضا نعود لكلمه او الحديث عن
القيمه العسكريه مقابل القيمه الرمزيه هنا
ثمانيه اشهر من الصراع على هذه المدينه
التي اطراف عديده تقول ليست مهمه ليست
بتلك القيمه الاستراتيجيه
وهذا ايضا يطرح السؤال من جديد يعني اين
نحن الاستمرار الهجوم الروسي من فاجنر في
مخبوط ولكن حقق الجيش الاوكراني بخركاف
بخرسون النصر يعني المنطقه الوحيده التي
بدات واستمرت فيها الهجومات وكانه اليوم
تريد رئيس بوتين ان يقدم شيء تبدل اربعه
قيادات مهمه في نفس المنطقه ولكن اليوم
عندما نتحدث عن مخمود بالحد الادنى هي
مهمه للجيش الاوكراني كسب الوقت ترك
المساحه فقط كي تاتي العتاد ويستعد الجيش
الاوكراني لحرب قد تعد في المستقبل سنرى
كم سيطول الحديث عن هذه المدينه
سنرى على العموم لسوء الحظ من يسكنها ايضا
الضحايا اكيد الى شكوى في المقام الاول
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا